hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a video where I play some
rage games now you guys know I don't
handle rage too well but there was a
game jam just recently where they
focused explicitly on games that made
you angry so I'm gonna be playing a
small snippet from as many as I possibly
can and it all starts with a game called
fish-out-of-water which is a lot like
getting over it I've heard now these
games aren't all like getting over it
but this one is about a fish and the
fish jumps towards Mouse that's nice oh
that's real nice oh boy
okay well how I've fallen over it I
can't get up oh I can jump farther if oh
yeah the farther the mouse the longer
the jam
alright oh boy this is still gonna be
bad ain't it alright oh no come on okay
I can do this oh no I can't do this oh
did I go oh I went oh going to the sewer
and you're good oh I get it
well they were kind enough to give me a
tutorial which is far better than I
guess Bennett fadi talking to you in
your ear the whole time oh this is
delightful oh no this is not gonna be
delightful No I have to wonder why this
fish decided to go on this wonderful
adventure oh boy ha I'm stuck in the
girl know the curve ass was good for me
[Music]
30 seconds 45 seconds in and I've
already broken the game I'm sorry
hee hee hoo ha ha ha hee hoo hoo
alright this salad
[Laughter]
what happens if I just keep going can I
get out of here oh look I'm out I'm free
oh no oh this is no I just started I'm
sorry I just started I didn't mean to
break it it's not my fault that's
probably my fault then again this was
made in a game jam so it's not gonna be
like a hundred percent polished but I'm
gonna try to try to succeed at this
where ever success may lie okay all
right I'm only assuming that I'm
supposed to go this way let me slide my
scaly body oh [ __ ] oh no my boat
I didn't even know I could do that yeah
hey yeah you know no no not into the
void again okay all right we got this I
can't go doofer no I can't go too sure
either Oh Frick I have enough chairs to
break this is only the first game in the
series of games that I've had oh yeah
yeah I hadn't heard of a rage game jam
before but it only seems logical at this
point considering considering that
they're simplistic enough to make their
I mean game jams are home for big games
and surgeon simulator what are they one
of the one of the rage games of your how
did I do this so easily before I had
this I had this so perfectly a good god
I had this so perfectly done oh god it's
so perfect I was going through the map
that's how good I was
oh come on oh you floppy [ __ ] okay
there we go all right slide my scaly
body all right not too far oh god [ __ ]
damn it
oh god it was better when I was
overconfident oh it's impossible the
judge distances here it's us it's
impossible at least it's not momentum
based based okay freak my dick oh no oh
come on fishy
come on fishy wishy come on Oh go no
don't go don't go go don't go oh boy oh
boy okay we're fine at least this is
better than a lot of the getting over it
clones out there oh man I mean the
mechanics of this are new so kind of
qualifies as its own I guess how did I
do this so confidently before there
please there I was fine [ __ ] okay this
is position get it distant no position
get it why there we go
up on the barrel up on the rock cool you
go here you go a little over and up and
there you go nice and easy nice come on
come on come on
Oh God
I had this so nicely before this is so
nice okay now jump and then jump it no
jump oh okay
let's nudge just okay I gotta get up on
that barrel
[Music]
yes yes yes and bleep yes okay all right
we're doing good we're doing good we're
doing good I can't believe you're doing
good
whoa yes okay huh
all right so far so goo I don't know if
anything's my way am I supposed to go in
that pipe or over
I'm gonna guess over who nailed it
huh nope didn't nail that Oh nailed it
all right I'm doing great
there's no way I'm gonna fail now look
at me now MA
mom mommy breath oh boy a precision ha
good thing I'm so [ __ ] precise so
good what happened to me I just I could
go through it the first time and then I
[ __ ] alit all over the place I can't
help but fuchal it I can't
it's like leaning a quarter on its edge
how I'm able to mmm I was so perfect
I was so perfect and now suddenly oh I'm
garbage I'm gone well I'm in a trash can
so I guess being [ __ ] garbage is fine
now
oh you answer
come on there we go okay made it made it
made it
you just got a squiggle it he's got
squiggle real good and I'm good at
squiggly I'm the best squiggly there
ever was I don't trust this at oh good
thing I don't trust anything at all no
no you wanted to so uh what do I do here
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay it's fine boy back in the trash
heap where I belong mobs are so we
please yes okay just got a nut [ __ ]
that's all that's all my problem this is
all my problem ever was skip to my Lou
skip to my Lou skip to my Lou skip Liske
bow ok skippity boom bah skip better be
buh buh buh boom ok but beep bop boop
beep all right
[Music]
it's the slightest of nudges Perrigo
that's gonna be the jump to end all
jumps a tip me like that why would you
do I don't slippies light off of here Oh
God get on the [ __ ] barrel no not in
the crevasse no I did I try oh how
quickly the brave have fallen no no okay
no come on
[ __ ] I'll take the boat with me [ __ ]
you did that no sound exactly like the
no that's all I have left in me I wish
this fish could talk I'm not even like
dialing it in oh [ __ ] come on no come on
come on why did I have to fall I didn't
even get the opportunity to do what I
wanted to do it slipped me enough why
did it slip me off oh there we go oh no
no you can bounce you floppy [ __ ] oh no
no come on [ __ ] out I launched that far
just go just go just go just go just go
now come on
not done loved-up I'm not done oh come
on
ah come on Jesus just oh my god it's
just the [ __ ] barrel oh my god don't
go in the mountain I saw you trying to
creep inside that mountain
you don't belong there you belong out
here in hell with me [ __ ] you okay what
the [ __ ] was that
come on Erica please stay oh please
please clapping please I'm back in it to
win it baby I'm back in I'm back in it
to win it baby I'm why did that happen
I'm back in it to win it baby
baby huh alright we've made it to our
quote unquote
safe zone even though nothing is safe in
this world no one was safe and nothing
is safe from nobody haha baby back up
there [ __ ] you thought that you could
it's times like this I ask why I do this
to myself
nope alright well go right back down you
know if anything I just don't like
progress that's just me as a person just
got a scooch alone [ __ ] can't be in a
hurry
or else I'll get worried I'm crying
because both that wasn't a clever thing
to say it God why am i rhyming okay back
here just give me a chance to make the
jump please that's all I ask just give
me a chance to make the jump that's fine
okay just give me a chance give me a
goddamn chance that's all I ask
god damn chance okay here we go for this
corner
boink yes yes yes no yes yes okay we're
fine oh my god oh my god oh my god
where do I go do I go that way I just
spit on my monitor which way do I go
why do I have a funny feeling I need to
be down there but I don't want to flop
down there I'm just gonna go for it
I hate floppy [ __ ] you floppy fuck-you
floppy [ __ ] come on I'm clicking gun
clicking on clicking why you know
jumping I spit on my monitor again there
we go know every [ __ ] time you floppy
bouncy [ __ ] I want to die I wanna die
I'm gonna die I want to die I want to
die I want to die stab me in the neck I
want to die I want to die put me in a
coffin bury me underground I want to die
I want to be dead everything I'm oh my
god I want to die now I want to die or
die oh this is the point of the game
where I got to turn my mic game down so
I don't blow out everyone's [ __ ]
eardrums if the Green River if the Grim
Reaper could come and rip my goddamn
soul out from under my body comes
something but I'm crying the Big Bounce
you think of bouncing out of bounds
there were you
you bouncy book or back hair down oh
yeah now I know we're back here now
because every single time I land it
happens to be on a knife's edge
oh you bouncy pieces yet yep see look
I'm standing up now oh no no no you
[ __ ] don't
alright I made it I made it
no are you guys gonna make it back why
do we have to make it back we don't have
to actually play this game
[Music]
okay
my bing-bong did me wrong
I'm not happy ok back on track
in it to win it I'm so ready like
spongebob
who the [ __ ] and go not too far yes just
like that
that is the good stuff okay just a
little bore okay I'm not gonna go crazy
now I'm just gonna go perfectly sane not
incredibly yes just like that baby just
like that okay I'm in that but that's
okay you know what I'm fine with that
oink yes no bad I am good
okay I'm good I'm good that's a hell of
a jump that okay
I think I need to be up there because no
even that would know that don't be on
your knifes okay oh boy okay okay
[ __ ] that's that's quite a leap I don't
know if I can make that maybe I need to
be up here too no okay that's okay
I don't like it at all
no I knew it I knew it I knew it no no
come on you can't even oh no why do I
think that'll work
what part of my brain just forgets oh
god oh my god okay I made it yay
no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you instant
jump in no no no no no god I was fine I
was fine I was fine
oh I was fine I was fine everything was
fine for okay alright oh my god no oh
[Music]
I'm just getting flustered that's all I
am that's all this is god stop sitting
on your edge okay I'm back in it to win
it a [ __ ] gang don't [ __ ] me it's all
ah it's all I asked literally I'm not
asking for much of anything I'm just
asking you to give me a job I didn't
trust it I didn't trust it I didn't
trust it and for good reason okay no god
[ __ ] damnit [ __ ] oh yeah a thousand
seconds crossed a thousand guys we did
it didn't think we'd get here but man
thank you to those who believed in me
and my failures oh no you don't owe no
you don't owe no you don't owe no you
don't owe no you don't owe okay all
right
alright alright
OOP no all right we're back here okay so
I think I'm not a hundred percent sure
but I think the secret is right here
yes oh I don't know her I went but I
went away okay but that's okay
everything's fine
ha how much farther must I be from the
end I don't imagine that this game would
be as long as Oh as the Bennett fought
II the Bennet body pop okay where am I
going over there I'd like to think so
ha ha ha ha where is this where am i oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right that took way too long I took
way too much time at that I spent like
an hour I feel good I feel good for what
I accomplished but I feel really bad
[Music]
okay
all right next up in the cavalcade of
Ditka tree is neuro BOTS this actually
won first place in the game jam why
didn't I do it first I don't know
because I didn't want to rage too hard
and yet you know we are let's play Oh
cry-baby normal are you crazy speed run
mode I don't know what game is on line
so others can see your name I don't know
can I just do normal oh no oh no oh no
this is how I control it oh this is the
worst thing what is that that looks
dangerous I don't like it Oh No all
right I think I can control this I know
well
I'm trying man
look look I can only do so much with
these controls okay why did that hit me
why did I I know why I died cuz that's
just a pure Lay's or ain't it
Jimmy the checkmark give it to me okay
all right then
I didn't know that was sweeps come on
okay well that's fine
I got the checkpoint and that's fine who
could do this on one go through I can't
even go two inches they they ran out of
texts for for the amount of bots that
I've destroyed oh boy that's you know
you could also just say Christmas is
gonna happen before I'm done but you
know well let's go with the J babes
thing I did it I did it you suck I'm
getting better at this ha unlike those
other games Oh
oh well [ __ ] alright well [ __ ] oh no
that's my ass that's my ass exploded
okay alright I miss your narration man
come on dude I know me dude I don't know
man I don't know man what do you want
from me go sit on the toilet
eat some food whatever you're talking
about you were just saying nonsensical
dribble anyway so what does it matter
oh that was it oh I did it
[ __ ] you I got it yeah all right let me
just see what hardcore is like speed run
mode no check no no I forgot overall
that's too fast that's not fair are you
out of your go [ __ ] [ __ ] no it's like
playing with inverted controls while
also taking shrooms I'm not doing it not
after what I've been doing I'm not doing
it no you know if you guys want to play
that you can I'm not in an emotionally
ready mood to go through that [ __ ] I
didn't think I was gonna go through all
the the [ __ ] before but I'm not
ready alright I got another game for you
so this one is called quit just as
simple as that
just call I get it okay this one's
called quit as you might have noticed
this game is going to be a waste of your
time
great if you're smart you'll quit the
game right now well I'm not very smart
as we have all determined what
oh I lose if I stray off the bat dumb
enough to not do what you wanted to do
without good reason
coming over you know then again I didn't
really understand that questioned it
seemed like a loop-de-loop of a question
and and my brain wasn't prepared for it
so you know no no it's just amazing Oh
No
is he gonna is it just it's just it's
just amazed the way out at the end of
the beginning or the beginning of the
end
what stop talking in circles stop your
philosophical circle-jerk
I don't want it I don't want any of it I
just want I just want you to inflict
your pain upon me then I'll leave like
that's the exchange that we have dear in
control or are you winning is your life
real or just pretend again it's you
Socrates here can you shove a [ __ ] in it
I don't want to be a part of that I just
want it doesn't even matter how hard you
try keep that in mind I designed this
rhyme to explain in due time that you
trying way too hard it's not worth it I
know it's not worth it this is the same
this the same is the same exact maze the
same exact maze it's the same
[Laughter]
No okay why do I slide down words that
come on I hate it okay all right okay
okay no okay no okay no how about how
about we don't do this how about we
don't okay Oh Time Lord valuable thing
watch it fly by as the pendulum swings
if they reverse the controls up is now
down down is now up well I could still
beat this you [ __ ] I've got enough
training and the inverted controls to be
able to control your [ __ ] okay it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
and I mean I want to quit the game who
you who you better believe me I want to
quit the game we were off to a bad start
of this relationship before we even left
the door there to the end of the day the
clock ticks life away
oh no the controls are reversed and it's
spinning oh okay
it's fine because I oh and it's spinning
and it's drifting ah
this is horrible okay ignore everything
I said about this being fine this is
actually horrible something else I want
to trust me I want to believe you butter
your bull press escape to ski I'm not
gonna shut up we've made my suffering
alone this is my special time and you're
invading you don't understand if you
think this is easy if you're like DOM
enough to not do what you wanted to do
without good reason
coming over you're just gonna repeat
what you've said before because if you
are I will throw my
computer out of my window oh my god and
dumb enough to not do what you wanted to
do without good reason coming over it's
gonna leave that same phrases yes yes
that beef that would equip meat is made
up so put away your makeup I told you
once I won't tell you again
it's a bad way huh understand that
lyrics
you're just saying song lyrics but I
don't get it the controls are normalized
now thank goodness but it's still spinny
drifty still doing this no that's no
that's right way maybe I don't even know
anymore life is valuable do you know my
life I don't think we're talking about
the same thing here oh how could I
forget the way out I've been doing it to
secrecy and then up here you know it's
not gonna work that's how this works
that's how this easy nice and calm and
when and do I'm taking your time right
behind you back you're talking to
yourself at night and the message coming
to your eyes says leave it alone perhaps
you should maybe I should
the controls are the reverse sin I
didn't even what kind of control wait
what doing it he just he's just crapping
out on me I guess we're done alright
there you have it that's the end thank
you everybody so much for watching if
for some godforsaken reason you want to
play these games for yourself I'll
provide them in the description check it
out there thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]